went to France
I went to France
so this thing came out of nowhere right
get invited to go to France
um and you know I don't like the French
you know it
if you had to pick six things I don't
like the French would be four of them
and uh so I got invited they were doing
a comedy fashion show this fellow kids
super
and at first they said kid super I
thought it was one of you know like a
make a wish fellas you know you simply
get those you know they got that 40 year
old in a cape or something and he's
you know he wants to jump out of a
window or whatever and they won't let
him
because he's
you know does he never
you know he's mentally he's really you
know because the devil tickled him
whenever he was being made or whatever
and he's not well
um but it wasn't it was a uh it was a
fashion
show
put on by this um fellow comb Delane
make sure I get his name correctly comb
Delaine yes any real beautiful fellow
man are really kind smart neat guy
um and I'd had a friend Aaron Levy that
was uh part of the John Elliott clothing
brand so I'd been around some clothing
fashion High fashion
and I don't know much about fashion you
know that I mean look at me
there you go and you know I don't
and uh you know I got three pairs of
pants I wear one of them all the time
this is it
these little camo deals or paper thin
but they're nice from North Face and I
like them
um
but anyway we get invited to this thing
and if they said it's going to be I mean
you're wearing I mean some of the linen
it's just damn fresh silk I mean this
you could smell a spider's [__] on it
you know this [__] is hot
hot off the eight arms baby you know
what I'm saying this [__] is fresh and
um
and so yeah we we we go we first of all
we get to the airport and they're taking
us on a jet I mean this thing Puma put
us on a jet
and it's uh I mean this thing was long
this thing had two bathrooms in it
and I pissed in both of them because you
know that boy
if there's I'm pissing it you know what
I'm saying I'm pissing at each end of
the yard baby
and I'll let the devil do the laundry
baby you know what I'm saying I'm
pissing when I get in something
that's always who I've been
you know as a child at night before I go
to bed I'd piss off each side of my bed
and I'd piss around it fraud stand on my
bed and urinate around it
just uh to keep
you know whatever bad stuff could come
get me to keep it away
so we went there uh who was there Andrew
Santino
um
uh Mateo Lane other comedians uh Stavros
halkias
um fari
and he's a French comedian
um
who else Jeff Ross couple of the
comedians
um yeah anyway so we went out on the
stage and we had to walk in a fashion
and we had to uh do the you know and do
some material on stage so that was part
of it
and it was just wow you know like
there's I mean it you know I I this was
the most nervous that I'd been
to do comedy in a long time because for
one
people are coming to ju they judge
clothing I mean this is like fancy
people this is like the fanciest people
everybody has a Blog everybody has a web
page everybody has a lawyer it's people
like that
you know uh
and so you get it's like I knew these
people were gonna be are judgmental
about clothes anyway they're gonna
they're they're here to judge clothing
all week
so if you throw in an outlier like a
comedian
who's coming in who's not even part of
their world
we're the easiest thing for them to hate
on oh I can hate on this guy oh easy
done comedian done
so I feel I was like oh these are my
first man and it was rich people bro
and I don't like the rich man
I've said it and you know it
and people say well man you make money
and I yeah I do
but I'll never be rich
I'll never be [__] infected with that
[__]
that [__] starts in your heart son
so I'm never I'm gonna be like that
and I know because when I get around
rich people I don't like them
and I've just felt that in there it's
that age-old energy man I know this is a
judgmental play people are judging
fashion people are here to be judged
so I know the easiest thing for some
blogger
which is basically just a job where you
are afraid to [__] fight
uh the easiest job for a blogger is to
say to point fingers at the outlier that
comes in to say this is bad
right
um
instead of you know saying this is good
from all the you know bribes or whatever
they get I don't know or whatever their
end goal is
but anyway to say this bad so I just
knew going up against it was going to be
tough and it turned out uh it was okay
and we did well and and um yeah the kids
super clothing you know it's nice neat
stuff and calm the guy who runs it was
very neat Andrew Schultz was there that
was fun to get to spend time with him
um it was great man that was exciting
um I went for a walk
oh
I didn't try to do too much in France
because I wasn't there long
and you get out in the streets and this
you know it's French
people are French and you know just
[__] Frenching around dog
but we got to go out at night we went
and they had nice music at night and
just the whole experience was fancy and
it actually ended up being a good
experience
um sometimes I carry old ideas into
things uh
uh and so I gotta kind of monitor that
um
but my nerves are warnings for me and
they say hey this is what's up
beware of this
and uh and I'm glad that they're there
those are instincts too sometimes it's
not nerves it's instincts
and you got to really ask them are you a
nerve are you an instinct tell me
you gotta figure it out
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one